This is the reason Speakeasy
with Nicolas Gillespie.
All right. Well, thank you for
coming out.
We are recording in Midtown
at the Blue Building, which is also
the home of the psychedelic
assembly.
And we are talking
tonight with the authors of
the Canceling of the American Mind,
how Cancel culture Undermines
trust, destroys institutions
and threatens us all.
But there is a solution.
I don't know about that subtitle,
but we have the authors.
They will explain it along with
everything else about this strange
world we find ourselves in.
Greg Luciano and Ricky Shallot.
Please welcome them.
Greg, as I suspect
many of you know, is the
head of FIRE, the Foundation for
Individual Rights and Expression.
And he's also the co-author
of a previous best selling book
called The Coddling of the American
Mind.
And his coauthor this time
is Ricky Shallot, who's a New York
City based journalist who was a
fellow at
FIRE researcher and
as a New York Post columnist,
is a host of the Lost Debate
podcast and also at times
of Reason contributor.
So please give it up for Greg and
Ricky.
Okay, So let's start with the
subtitle.
Okay. The book is called The
Canceling of the American Mind.
And then the subtitle is Cancel
Culture Undermines Trust, Destroys
Institution and Threatens us
All...
But there is a solution.
Yeah. Okay.
There was some debate about that.
I wanted an emoticon in there.
Okay. You know that I might have
kept the sentence going, but why
don't we start?
Ricky, what is the what's the
elevator pitch for this book?
What is it about and why is it
relevant now?
Well, I think it's two-fold.
On the first front, people are still
saying that cancel culture does not
exist, which is absolutely crazy and
defies all statistics
fundamentally.
But also, cancel culture
is not just about the people that
are torn down, it's about the
epistemic crisis that it creates and
the devastation of the body
of common knowledge that we all
share and and also the undermining
of trust in between people
interpersonally.
And for me, as a young person, the
undermining of of
being able to grow up and have the
freedom to fumble and make mistakes
as well. So I think it's important
on a ton of different levels.
I have to say, as an old person,
yeah, you know, tough.
You should have been born when I was
born, but would you
agree? What is the working
definition of cancel culture?
It's basically we're trying to
give it the name of this historical
era that we're in.
I'm a First Amendment lawyer.
I'm big on the history of freedom
of speech and a lot of what we call
mass censorship events have names.
So alien sedition in 1798,
even those really Sedition Act of
1790, the Red Scare one
TS Red Scare two also known as
McCarthyism, etc.
PMRC, the
comic book scare.
So basically we're proposing more or
less that this be historical
definition of a unique and weird
period where there's been a lot of
people losing their jobs because of
their opinion. That's really one of
the things we're trying to show is
this is on par with any
of these previous moments of mass
censorship and actually exceeds them
in terms of numbers of professors
fired.
Yeah. Talk a bit about the
professors, because, I mean, there
are a couple of different sites,
right, or locations where this is
particularly strong academia,
clearly one of them.
What are the numbers that you're
talking about?
Yeah, so this was an
interesting thing. We now have a
great research Department of Fire
and that was, you know, partially a
labor of love on my part because I
was always the lawyer who was
pretending to be fire a social
scientist.
But we've been able to grow it.
That's how we actually have our
campus free speech rankings, which
is based on 13 different factors.
So real quick, through the stats
and so and our definition is
the the uptick of
campaigns beginning around 2014
to get people fired, de-platformed,
expelled, and and the
culture of fear that resulted from
that. And I think it's always
important to root numbers in
comparisons.
When I started at FIRE,
I started, I actually landed
in Philadelphia at 9:10
a.m. on 9/11,
all all of my first cases were
involving people who said jerky
or insensitive things about
the attacks or people
who said, Let's go get those
terrorists, but said it in a
considered to be rude way.